>>> WELCOME TO THE GROUP CHAT
LIVE IN THE BLEACHER REPORT
PRESENTED BY FAN DUEL.
I'M CABBIE RICHARDS.
SHE'S TAPPED INTO MORE ANALYTICS
THAN DARYL MOREY, ERIN DOLAN.
AND THEN THE MAN OF THE PEOPLE,
GREG IVORY.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
WE KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN HITTING A
BUNCH -- NOT A BUNCH BUT A FEW
BIG PARLAYS RECENTLY.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN OVERLY
GENEROUS WITH THE MERCH.
WILL THAT CONTINUE TODAY?
>> OF COURSE, CABBIE.
TODAY -- I MEAN, IS THE SKY
BLUE, IS TODAY THURSDAY, YES, TO
BOTH ANSWERS.
THEREFORE, WE ARE CONTINUING
GIVING AWAY MERCH.
I GOT HOODIES, JERSEYS, GOING TO
HOOK FOUR OF YOU UP WITH $125 TO
PICK OUT WHATEVER JERSEY YOU
WANT.
AND I'M GIVING THAT FIRST ONE
RIGHT NOW.
LET ME INTRODUCE THE NEW PEOPLE
TO THE SHOW, THIS RIGHT HERE,
CABBIE, ERIN, IS THE HANDY DANDY
iPAD.
THIS IS HOW YOU WIN YOUR JERSEYS
AND HOODIES.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, CABBIE, I
SEE COFFEE BLACK SENDING GOOD
VIBES.
COFFEE BLACK SAYS, K.D. IS
SCORING 31 -- ACTUALLY, THIS IS
BAD, I'M SO SORRY.
THIS IS BAD VIBES, BUT OH, HE
SAID K.D. SCORED 31, KYRIE
SCORED 36, EQUALS 56 POINTS.
WE WANT THE OVER.
I'M SO SORRY, YOU'RE GOING TO
WALK AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
SLIM REAPER 22 SAYS 64.
OH, MY, MORE BAD VIBES.
>> WE HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN TO
THAT PART OF THE SHOW YET, EVEN
THOUGH WE DID POST IT ON -- IN
THE APP EARLIER TODAY.
>> THEY KNOW, I'M LOOKING FOR
GOOD VIBES.
HERE WE GO.
THIN SANITY 5, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY A JERSEY.
HE SAYS 74 POINTS TONIGHT FOR
K.D., KYRIE.
CABBIE, THEY KNOW, THEY KNOW
ABOUT THE VIBES.
WE POSTED IT ON THE STORY.
>> WE DID.
>> THE THUMB NAIL ON THE APP.
WE'RE RIDING THE OVER HERE.
>> OKAY.
SO FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE JUST
JOINING THE STREAM WHO DIDN'T
TAP IN WITH THE SOCIAL POSTS,
LOOK, THE BROOKLYN NETS HAVE
REALLY ASSEMBLED A TEAM OF
AVENGERS BECAUSE THEIR
SUPERSTARS PLAY LIKE SUPERHEROES
AND THEY HAVE THE BEST PURE
SHOOTER IN THE NBA RAINING DOWN
THREES.
THE NETS HAVE A NICE 2-0 CUSHION
WITHOUT JAMES HARDEN WHICH IS
WILD TO THINK ABOUT.
SO TODAY IN THE B/R APP WE ASKED
YOU TO DROP YOUR BEST GUESS FOR
KYRIE AND KEVIN DURANT'S
COMBINED POINTS.
NOW, FANDUEL IS OFFERING A B/R
BETTING ODDS BOOST ON THE
COMBINED POINTS TOTAL.
LET'S LOOK AT THE GRAPHIC HERE.
IT WENT FROM PLUS 150, BOOSTED
TO PLUS 200 WILL KYRIE IRVING
AND KEVIN DURANT, THE KANYE
WESTS OF THE NBA AND THE SLIM
REAPER SCORE 65 POINTS OR MORE
TONIGHT IN MILWAUKEE?
THAT IS THE QUESTION.
YOU HAVE BEEN ON THE NETS FOR A
FEW MONTHS NOW AND I LOST
ANOTHER $100 BET TO YOU.
THIS IS A SHOW WHERE WE HAVE
SOME FULL DISCLOSURE SO I LOST
$100 TO YOU BECAUSE YOU SAID
BACK IN DECEMBER BEFORE HARDEN
WAS TRADED THAT THE NETS WILL
WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
THEY'RE IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT
RIGHT NOW.
SO I'LL GET THAT TO YOU WHEN WE
GET PAID.
OKAY, SO ANYWAY, WE KNOW YOUR
DUDE IS KEVIN DURANT.
OTHER PEOPLE IN THE COMMENTS
WHOSE DUDE IS ALSO DURANT AND
THINK THE 65-POINT MARKER
PLATEAU IS IN VIEW FOR THAT
DYNAMIC DUO?
>> CABBIE, EARLIER I SAW NOT A
LOT OF GOOD VIBES BUT HOPEFULLY
THE VIBES HAVE CHANGED.
THE SHOW AS THIS STARTED WE'RE
INTO IT A LITTLE BIT.
BUT LET ME TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
HOW MANY POINTS WILL KYRIE AND
K.D. PUT UP TONIGHT COMBINED,
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES TO THE
BEST COMMENTERS.
AT THE END -- NO, I'M GOING TO
GIVE AWAY A JERSEY AT THE END OF
THE GAME TONIGHT.
I'M GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
WE'LL DM YOU GUYS.
DM YOU GUYS.
GIVE AWAY A JERSEY AT THE END OF
THE GAME TONIGHT.
ERIN, HOW MANY DO YOU THINK
KYRIE AND K.D. ARE PUTTING UP
TONIGHT?
>> IN THIS SERIES, K.D. IS
AVERAGING 31 AND KYRIE 24.
I HAD TO TAKE YOU BACK TO WHEN
THE NETS PLAYED IN MILWAUKEE,
MAY 2 AND 4 AND THE NETS LOST
BOTH.
IN THE SECOND GAME, K.D. DROPPED
32 AND KYRIE HAD 38 SO BOTH OF
THE PLAYERS CAN GO OFF IN
MILWAUKEE SO I'M NOT WORRIED,
GIVE ME OVER 65.
>> 65 IS KIND OF A HIGH TOTAL
EVEN THOUGH AS YOU SAID, ERIN,
THEY CAN BOTH GO OFF.
I'M LEANING ON THE UNDER.
LOOK, THE BUCKS WERE EMBARRASSED
IN GAME 2.
THEY WERE DOWN BY AS MANY AS 49
POINTS.
THEY WERE LIT UP RIGHTFULLY SO
ON NATIONAL TELEVISION, SPORTS
RADIO, BASKETBALL, TWITTER.
ALL OVER THE PLACE, SO THIS IS A
GUT CHECK GAME FOR THE MILWAUKEE
BUCKS ON THEIR HOME COURT IN
GAME 3.
KYRIE IRVING AND THE SLIM REAPER
ARE BASICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO STOP
BUT THEY CAN BE CONTAINED.
BUDENHOLZER IS GOING TO ADDRESS
THE LINEUPS AND HE HAS TO THROW
SOME DIFFERENT LOOKS AT THE
WALL, GIVE MORE JUICE IN LIEU OF
SOME DEFENSE.
BUT LISTEN, I'M SAYING UNDER 65
POINTS TONIGHT IN GAME 3.
ARE YOU LOCKING IN THIS SPECIFIC
BET?
65 OR MORE AS OFFERED BY
FANDUEL?
>> I'M IN THE COMMENTS, LET ME
GET INTO THE COMMENTS AND THEN
GIVE MY TAKE.
I HAVE NOT RONALD ACUNA JR. --
>> HE'S BACK.
>> 38 FOR KYRIE HE SAYS 78
POINTS IN TOTAL.
THOSE ARE GOOD VIBES.
>> GOOD LORD.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
GOOD VIBES.
>> WOW.
>> IT'S GOOD VIBES.
ALL ABOUT THE VIBES.
I'VE GOT INHEAL 24 SAYS HE'S
GOING WITH 70.
70 FOR THE DUB FOR KYRIE AND
K.D.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I HAVE ONE MORE.
K.D. 43, KYRIE, 25.
TOTALLING 68.
THEREFORE, THOSE ARE GOOD VIBES.
I'M GOING TO KEEP THE GOOD VIBES
GOING HERE.
WE HAVE KYRIE IRVING WHO IS AN
AUTOMATIC BUCKET AND WE ALSO
HAVE KEVIN DURANT WHO IS ALSO AN
AUTOMATIC BUCKET.
THEY HAVE BEEN BALLING -- THEY
HAVE BEEN BALLING IN THE FIRST
TWO GAMES, NETS UP 2-0.
I DON'T SEE WHAT'S GOING TO
CHANGE, CABBIE.
I REALLY DON'T THINK ANYTHING
WILL CHANGE.
IT'S OVER PLUS 200, GIVE ME THE
PLUS MONEY.
LET'S GO.
WE'RE RIDING TOGETHER.
>> TAKE THE PLUS MONEY, IT'S
PLUS 200.
>> PLUS 200.
>> THAT'S A GOOD BOOST.
MAYBE YOU GUYS ARE BOTH --
WHAT'S THE COMMENTER'S NAME,
INHALE 420?
ANYWAY, KEEP IT MOVING.
FOR THE SECOND YEAR IN A ROW,
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS ARE DOWN 0-2
IN A PLAYOFF SERIES.
HERE WE ARE IN YEAR EIGHT.
THE 26-YEAR-OLD GREEK GOD,
GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO IN
MILWAUKEE.
DO YOU BELIEVE HE'LL WIN AN NBA
CHAMPIONSHIP FOR THAT CITY?
YEAR EIGHT OR NINE OR BEYOND?
LET'S LOOK AT THE ODDS FOR THIS
YEAR'S CHAMPIONSHIP TITLE.
THE LEADERS IN THE CLUBHOUSE,
BROOKLYN NETS, FOLLOWED BY THE
NUMBER ONE OVERALL SEED IN THE
NBA THE UTAH JAZZ.
PHOENIX IS UP 2-0 IN THE SERIES
AGAINST DENVER THEY'RE IN THE
MIX.
SOME GREAT VALUE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE PACK.
THE CLIPPERS, SIXERS, BUCKS AND
THEN SOME SUPER LONG SHOTS THE
ATLANTA HAWKS, 0-2, DENVER
NUGGETS.
ARE YOU GIVING AWAY HOODIES OR
JERSEYS THIS TIME?
>> BOTH.
GET IN THE COMMENT AND TELL ME
IF YOU THINK THAT GIANNIS WILL
WIN A RING WITH MILWAUKEE THIS
YEAR OR EVER.
ERIN, TALK TO ME.
TALK TO ME, TALK TO ME.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, AS WE JUST SAW --
>> RING -- THIS YEAR OR EVER,
SORRY.
>> NO, YOU'RE GOOD.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'LL EVER WIN
IT, GIANNIS BY HIMSELF.
BOY, DID THEY SLIP DOWN THE ODDS
BOARDS.
I DON'T THINK GIANNIS WINS A
RING WITH MILWAUKEE THIS YEAR AT
ALL.
YOU KNOW, A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE
AS I SAID BEFORE THE SHOW SAID F
THE BUCKS AND "F" IS FOR FADE.
NOW, IF THEY'RE PLAYING A
DIFFERENT TEAM THAN THE BROOKLYN
NETS I WOULD SAY THERE'S SOME
TYPE OF HOPE OF THEM WINNING A
RING DEPENDING ON WHO WAS GOING
TO COME OUT OF THE WEST THIS
YEAR.
BUT GIANNIS THE TWO-TIME MVP
GOING AGAINST K.D., KYRIE,
CARDIN IS ON THE BENCH, BUT
GIANNIS NEEDS ANOTHER SUPERSTAR
AROUND HIM IN MILWAUKEE.
>> I MEAN, I HEARD NO LIES.
AND I'M GOING TO TRY TO MAKE A
CASE FOR MILWAUKEE.
SO I'M GOING TO SAY YES, HE WINS
A TITLE WITH THE BUCKS WITH THIS
CAVEAT, BY NEXT YEAR.
IF HE DOESN'T WIN THIS YEAR AND
THERE'S STILL TIME, THEY'RE DOWN
0-2, IT'S NOT INSURMOUNTABLE.
THEY'RE MISSING DANTE D, IF THEY
DON'T WIN THIS YEAR, BUDENHOLZER
IS LIKELY TO GET FIRED.
PERHAPS ALL OF THE HEALTHY --
BUT AFTER THAT, THEN IT'S LIKE
IF THEY I DON'T WIN IN 2022 OR
IN 2021, I THINK GIANNIS IS OUT
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN SUPERSTARS
FORCE THEIR WAY OUT OF TOWN.
WE SAW JAMES HARDEN DO IT THIS
YEAR.
RUSSELL WESTBROOK, HE'S A
FRANCHISE PLAYER, JOHN WALL AND
RUSSELL THEY DID A FLIP-FLOP.
SO THERE -- WE'RE HEARING ABOUT
DAMIAN LILLARD POTENTIALLY
FORCING HIS WAY OUT OF PORTLAND
IF HE DOESN'T GET THE COACH THAT
HE WANTS.
SO WE LOVE THE MOVEMENT IN THE
NBA, WE LOVE THE HOPE
TRAFFICKING SO I'M SAYING, YES,
GIANNIS WILL WIN A TITLE WITH
MILWAUKEE IN 2021 OR 2022.
IF NOT, HE'S OUT.
WE KNOW THAT BROOKLYN IS THE
SQUAD THAT YOU SELECTED TO WIN
THE NBA CHAMPIONSHIP SO IF THAT
COMES TRUE, DO YOU THINK THAT
GIANNIS WILL WIN A TITLE WITH
BROOKLYN NEXT YEAR OR EVER, AS
HE SAID SO POETICALLY?
>> LET ME GIVE AWAY SOME JERSEYS
OR ONE JERSEY AND A HOODIE.
>> ARE YOU GIVING AWAY GIANNIS
JERSEYS?
>> WELL, IF THE FANS -- YOU
KNOW, CABBIE, I'M A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
I DON'T -- YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
TRYING TO STRAY ANY FAN TO PICK
ONE JERSEY.
I WANT THEM TO PICK WHATEVER
JERSEY THEY WANT.
WE'LL GIVE THEM THE MONEY FOR
THE JERSEYS THEY WANT.
BUT I HAVE JOHN SCHNEIDER IS
SAYING, NO, GIANNIS WILL NOT WIN
A RING WITH MILWAUKEE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A SWEATSHIRT.
I GOT MOTIVATED IN THE COMMENTS
GIVING US THE SCOOBY-DOO, AND
SAYING NO, SCOOBY-DOO SAYING NO
MOTIVATED.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I THINK IT'S JERSEY TIME.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, I SEE -- I
SEE -- OH, THIS IS FUNNY.
IT'S A LOT OF FUNNY GIFTS BUT I
GOT JAYLEE RIGHT HERE, GOT THE
SHANNON SHARPE NO GIFT RIGHT
THERE.
HEY, JAYLEE 199, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A JERSEY TODAY.
NOW, LET ME JUMP IN HERE.
WELL, WE ALL KNOW WE DON'T THINK
HE'S GOING TO WIN THIS YEAR.
I AGREE WITH ERIN, HE'S A PIECE
AWAY, HE'S DEFINITELY A PIECE
AWAY FROM WINNING THE
CHAMPIONSHIP OUT THERE IN
MILWAUKEE.
WILL I SEE THAT HAPPENING?
NO.
I DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING IN
MILWAUKEE.
I'LL BE HONEST, I DON'T SEE IT.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT GETTING RID
OF THE COACH.
THEY BROUGHT IN JRUE HOLIDAY TO
BE THE OTHER SUPERSTAR WITH
GIANNIS.
I THINK THEY NEED SOMETHING
ELSE.
KHRIS MIDDLETON IS A GOOD
PLAYER, BUT THEY NEED SOMETHING
ELSE BUT I'LL TELL GIANNIS WHAT
TO DO.
I'LL TELL HIM WHAT TO DO.
HE NEEDS TO BE ON THE FIRST
PRIVATE JET FROM MILWAUKEE TO
SAN FRANCISCO TO GO TALK TO THE
SPLASH BROTHERS AND --
>> GET OUT OF HERE!
>> AND THEN --
>> THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> HE MIGHT BE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH WINNING MULTIPLE
CHAMPIONSHIPS, THAT'S WHAT HE
NEEDS TO DO.
>> LIKE FRANK OCEAN ONCE SUNG,
WHAT'S A KING TO THE GREEK GOD?
HE'S NOBODY'S ROBIN TO THE
BATMAN.
IF HE GOES TO GOLDEN STATE WE
KNOW THAT STEPH CURRY, HE'S
APPROACHING THE TOP 15 OF
GREATEST OF ALL TIME TO EVER
HAVE PLAYED THE SPORT.
THE GREEK GOD IS NOT GOING
THERE.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MUCH FLAK
ANTETOKOUNMPO WOULD GET?
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE K.D., HE JOINED THE
73-WIN TEAM.
>> I DON'T -- I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHENEVER A PLAYER COMES TO JOIN
THE WARRIORS, IT'S SUCH A
PROBLEM, IT'S SUCH A PROBLEM.
WE HAVE BIG THREES IN NEW YORK.
I DON'T HEAR THEM SAYING NOTHING
ABOUT THAT.
THEY HAVE -- I MEAN, JAMES
HARDEN, KYRIE IRVING, SLIM.
>> WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
THE BIG THREE IN BROOKLYN THE
WHOLE SEASON.
AS SOON AS HARDEN --
>> THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE
WARRIORS TREATMENT.
THE WHOLE UNIVERSE HATED THE
WARRIORS FOR K.D. COMING OVER.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT BROOKLYN
BECAUSE IT'S LOVE.
IT'S NOT THE SAME.
>> LISTEN, YOU'RE SHOWING A LOT
OF LOVE, BUT WE KNOW SOMETIMES
IN COMMENT SECTIONS AND OUT
THERE ON BASKETBALL TWITTER A
LOT OF HATERS AND A LOT OF
BURNER ACCOUNTS.
WE MOVE ON WITH THE GROUP
CHAT -- I'M NOT SAYING YOU HAVE
A BURNER ACCOUNT.
IN GAME 1, VERSUS THE L.A.
CLIPPERS, DONOVAN MITCHELL
SCORED MORE POINTS AND IT'S THE
MOST HE'S EVER SCORED.
SO TONIGHT IS GAME 2 IN FRONT OF
THE PACKED HOUSE IN SALT LAKE
CITY.
SO LET'S TALK ABOUT MITCHELL'S
POINTS, REBOUNDS AND ASSISTS.
BEFORE WE GET INTO THIS
CONVERSATION, DO YOU HAVE ANY
MORE MERCH TO GIVE AWAY?
>> OF COURSE.
>> GOOD.
>> WELL, WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY
TO DO IS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
TELL ME HOW MANY POINTS,
REBOUNDS AND ASSISTS MITCHELL IS
PUTTING UP TONIGHT.
I'M GIVING AWAY A HOODIE AND I
HAVE ONE MORE JERSEY TO GIVE
AWAY IN THE NEXT SEGMENT.
ERIN, ARE YOU ON THE OVER OR THE
UNDER HERE WITH DONOVAN
MITCHELL?
>> IT'S INTERESTING, THE UTAH'S
HEAD COACH SAID HE WAS SICK AND
HE SCORED THE FIRST TEN POINTS
FOR THE JAZZ IN THE SECOND.
OVER 40 1/2.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THAT OVER LIKE
I JUST MENTIONED.
EVEN ALONE WITH WHAT HE'S
AVERAGING DURING THE REGULAR
SEASON THIS COULD HIT AND LAST
GAME WITH HIS POINTS ALONE HE
WAS ABLE TO HIT OVER 40 1/2.
I'M GOING WITH THE OVER THERE.
>> BEFORE I GET INTO MITCHELL I
HAVE TO SALUTE RUDY GOBERT FOR
WINNING HIS THIRD DEFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR AWARD.
IN MY OPINION, THE STIFLE TOWER
IS THE MOST IMPORTANT PLAYER ON
THE UTAH JAZZ.
WE SAW IN GAME 1 HE BLOCKS
MARCUS MORRIS, WITH THE
THREE-POINT SHOT IT WAS MAGICAL.
I'LL SALUTE DRAYMOND GREEN
BECAUSE HE DID IT TO KYLE LOWRY
IN GAME 5 AND THAT'S THE REASON
WE DIDN'T -- WE BEING THE
TORONTO RAPTORS IN FIVE GAMES.
SO SALUTE TO GREEN WHO HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE INSIDE THE NBA.
DONOVAN MITCHELL, THERE'S NO
MIKE CONLEY TODAY, STILL
BATTLING THE HAMSTRING INJURY.
SO THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
HIM TO GET THE ASSISTS AND I
THINK THE REBOUNDS WILL BE DOWN
UNDER FOUR BECAUSE GOBERT IS IN
THE MIDDLE AND MORRIS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
MAYBE MAYBE NOT MARCUS MORRIS,
BUT PAUL GEORGE AND KAWHI
LEONARD.
SO HE'S NOT GOING TO SHOOT 15
THREE-POINTERS AGAIN LIKE HE DID
IN GAME 1 AND HE'S NOT GOING TO
SCORE 45 POINTS AGAIN.
SO I'M GOING TO TAKE THE UNDER.
EVEN THOUGH THE NUMBER IS
DEFINITELY WITHIN REACH.
UNDER 40 1/2 POINTS, REBOUNDS
AND AN ASSIST FOR ME WE'LL -- I
WILL BET ON IT TONIGHT.
WHY NOT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT SPIDER
MITCHELL'S PRODUCTION TONIGHT IN
GAME 2?
>> CABBIE, I'LL GET TO THAT.
I'LL GET TO THAT.
BUT I HAVE SOME FANS IN THE
COMMENTS THAT WANT HOODIES.
SO --
>> GIVE IT TO THEM.
>> LET ME TALK TO THEM REAL
QUICK.
I GOT NOT ZACH LaVINE IS IN THE
COMMENT -- HE'S GOING TO HAVE --
HE'S GOING TO HAVE AT LEAST 33.
HE CAN GET SIX ASSISTS AND TWO
REBOUNDS, I BELIEVE THAT IS --
IS THAT OVER?
YEAH, THAT'S OVER.
THAT'S BARELY OVER.
THERE'S BARELY OVER, BUT THAT IS
OVER.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU NOT ZACH
LaVINE.
YOU HAVE A HOODIE.
I HAVE NOT MOCK SAYS OVER FOR
SURE.
SHOUT-OUT TO YOU, NOT MOCK.
YOU'RE ROCKING WITH THE OVER.
CABBIE, I'M TRYING TO SEE IF
YOU'RE GETTING ANY LOVE WITH THE
UNDER HERE.
IN THE COMMENTS I SEE RYAN RAY
HE SAYS 34 POINTS, THREE
REBOUNDS AND SEVEN ASSISTS.
>> THAT'S OVER.
>> I THINK THAT GETS IT DONE.
THAT'S THE OVER.
>> ARE THE PEOPLE FORGETTING
THAT PAUL GEORGE AND KAWHI
LEONARD PLAY FOR THE L.A.
CLIPPERS?
ARE THEY FORGETTING THAT?
>> CABBIE, WAIT WAIT WAIT WAIT.
>> THESE ARE TWO OF THE BEST
WING DEFENDERS.
>> DOESN'T MEAN THAT MITCHELL
WON'T HIT THIS THOUGH.
>> LISTEN, HE'S NOT GOING FOR
45.
HE'LL GET CLAMPS PUT ON HIM AND
A BUNCH OF BODIES THROWN AT HIM
IN GAME 2.
>> CABBIE, IF THIS WAS AUGUST,
WHEN WE WERE IN THE BUBBLE LAST
YEAR, I WOULD BE RIGHT THERE
WITH YOU.
I WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE
DOGS THAT ARE IN L.A.
>> YEAH.
>> ROCK -- THEY'RE ALL ON THIS
CLIPPERS TEAM.
THEY STILL HAVE DOGS, DON'T GET
ME WRONG.
THEY'RE STILL DOGS BUT THEY HAVE
BEEN PLAYING -- I DON'T KNOW.
NOT LIKE -- NOT LIKE HOW I
THOUGHT THEY WOULD LAST YEAR IN
THE BUBBLE.
NOT LIKE HOW I TALKED THEM UP
LAST YEAR IN THE BUBBLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN
L.A., I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON.
PAUL GEORGE, PATRICK BEVERLEY,
THE DEFENSIVE STOPPERS OUT THERE
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN STOPPING
ANYBODY IN THIS PLAYOFFS.
THEY HAVEN'T STOPPED LUKA, LUKA
WAS BALLING AT WILL WHENEVER HE
WANTED TO.
THEY DID NOT STOP DONOVAN
MITCHELL IN GAME 1.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WHAT'S GOING TO CHANGE?
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
ROTATIONS, DEFENSIVE
ASSIGNMENTS.
MAYBE SWITCHING AROUND THE
PERSONNEL, FORCING HIM OFF
ACTION, TRYING TO MAKE JOE
ANGLES INITIATE THE OFFENSE?
THEY'RE GOING TO --
>> CABBIE --
>> ENGELS COULD HAVE SEVEN OR
EIGHT REBOUNDS OR ASSISTS
TONIGHT.
>> MAYBE.
IT SOUNDS GOOD.
THEIR TRACK RECORD AS OF LATE IN
STOPPING SUPERSTARS HASN'T BEEN
GOOD.
AND MY GUY, MITCHELL, HE HAS
TAKEN A STEP UP TO BE CALLED THE
SUPERSTAR.
I WILL SAY, DONOVAN MITCHELL IS
NOW A SUPERSTAR.
>> YES.
BUT MITCHELL SOME 6'1".
>> NOTHING IS GOING TO CHANGE.
I'M GOING WITH THE OVER.
WHAT IS -- 6'1".
>> A BIG-TIME DIFFERENCE.
IT'S A BIG-TIME DIFFERENCE.
>> WHAT DID THAT HAVE --
>> LUKA IS 6'7".
>> DID 6'1", MATTER IN GAME 1?
>> HE TOOK 15 THREE-POINTERS,
BRO.
LIKE 45 POINTS AND THEY ONLY WON
BY THREE.
LIKE YOU HAD A GREAT PERFORMANCE
FROM MITCHELL AND THEY ONLY WON
BY THREE.
NOT HAPPENING.
>> CABBIE, CABBIE, I'VE GOT WEE
SMITH -- I'M GIVING AWAY A
JERSEY RIGHT HERE.
JUST BECAUSE I WANT TO.
I WANT TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY SO
WHY NOT?
THE CLIPPERS, THE CLIPPERS, MAN,
I THOUGHT SO HIGHLY OF THEM.
HERE WE GO, IN THE COMMENTS
GIVING AWAY A JERSEY.
I HAVE WEE SMITH 34 SAYS 40
POINTS.
DOUBLE-DOUBLE TONIGHT FOR
SPIDER.
YOU HEARD IT HERE FIRST.
SHOUT YOU OUT TO YOU, WEE SMITH
44.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY.
A JERSEY, YES, A JERSEY.
>> HE'S GOING TO GET CLAMPED
LIKE J MANI FACING DERICK COLE.
NOT THE SAME SPORT BUT A SWING
AND A MISS.
LAST WEEK, WE BUILT OUR FIRST
BASKET PARLAYS AND TONIGHT FOR
TONIGHT'S DOUBLEHEADER WE HAVE
BROOKLYN AND MILWAUKEE AND THEN
WE HAVE LOS ANGELES AT UTAH.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS
FOR FIRST GAME.
I LIKE SOME OF THE VALUE DOWN
LOW THERE.
AS WE SEE THE BOARD, KYRIE,
BROOK LOPEZ, P.J. TUCKER.
PROFESSIONAL JUSTICE TUCKER.
LOOK AT THE SECOND GAMES' ODDS,
MITCHELL, WE WERE JUST SPEAKING
ABOUT HIM.
PLUS 410.
BOGDANOVICH IS NICE.
MARCUS MORRIS DOWN THERE AT --
TO FILL OUT THE BOARD.
SO OKAY, SO LET THE ODDS SINK
IN.
THESE ARE SOME PRESSURE FILLED
PROPS BECAUSE THEY RESOLVE RIGHT
AWAY.
RIGHT FROM THE TIP, FIRST
POSSESSION OR TWO.
ZERO PRESSURE ON YOU RIGHT NOW,
BUT IS IT JERSEY TIME?
>> IT'S JERSEY -- NO, IT IS --
IT IS --
>> FINISH THROUGH WITH THAT.
>> IT IS JERSEY TIME.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL ME
WHO IS A LOCK TO HIT FIRST
BASKET IN EACH GAME, ERIN?
ME AND CABBIE HAVE BEEN GOING
BACK AND FORTH.
I WANT TO HEAR YOU.
I WANT TO HEAR YOUR TAKE.
WHO'S YOUR LOCK FOR FIRST BASKET
PARLAY?
>> SO FOR THE FIRST GAME, CHRIS
MIDDLETON, PLUS 500.
OBVIOUSLY THE BUCKS ARE AT HOME
SO I'M GOING WITH HIM.
SECOND GAME, I'M GOING WITH
KAWHI LEONARD PLUS 700.
FINDING VALUE THERE AND I THINK
SINCE THE CLIPPERS DID SO WELL
IN FIRST HALF OF LAST GAME TO
COME OUT AND DO THAT AGAIN.
SO FIRST BASKET, PARLAY.
>> ERIN, I LIKE YOUR TRAIN OF
THOUGHT THERE.
I'M GOING WITH THE GREEK GOD,
GIANNIS ANTETOKOUNMPO, TO GET IT
STARTED FOR MILWAUKEE.
THEY GOT EMBARRASSED IN GAME 2.
THIS IS A GUT CHECK GAME.
IF WE WERE BETTING ON THE RACE
TO TEN, I'D LOCK IN THE
MILWAUKEE BUCKS AND THEN THE
SECOND GAME, I'M GOING WITH PAUL
GEORGE.
HE HAD A PANDEMIC "P" TYPE OF
PERFORMANCE IN GAME 1, SO I CAN
JUST IMAGINE THAT GEORGE EITHER
PUT UP SOME SHOTS AT AN EMPTY
YMCA IN SALT LAKE CITY AND GOT
TO THE BUILDING EARLY AND PUT UP
SOME SHOTS TODAY.
GIVE MY PAUL GEORGE ON THE NICE
MID RANGE OR THREE-POINTER TO
GET IT STARTED FOR THE CLIPPERS
IN THE CLIPPERS AND JAZZ GAME
TONIGHT.
WHAT IS YOUR TWO-LEG FIRST
BASKET PARLAY?
>> CABBIE, BEFORE I GET INTO MY
PARLAY, I'M GOING TO GIVE OUT
HOODIES AND A JERSEY.
WHY NOT?
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE HERE FOR
THE JERSEYS.
THEY'RE HERE FOR THE HOODIES.
I HAVE -- I'M IN THE COMMENTS,
CABBIE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND I HAVE
WAGS WORLD TIN.
THEY'RE ROCKING WITH -- THEIR
COMMENT JUST LEFT.
WELL, HE SAID KYRIE.
HE DID NOT PUT A PARLAY TONIGHT
BUT THAT IS OKAY.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A HOODIE.
HE SAID KYRIE FOR THE FIRST
BASKET IN THE BROOKLYN GAME.
I HAVE JA GANG OPILE, 796 SAYS
KYRIE AND SPIDER.
KYRIE AND SPIDER, THEN HE GAVE
US THE HONEY BEE EMOJI.
SHOUT-OUT, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY A
JERSEY.
I HAVE PARLAY PETE IN THE
BUILDING.
HE'S IN THE BUILDING, HE SAYS
JOE HARRIS AND KAWHI ARE LOCKS.
GOT THE VALUE, GET AT THEM.
A LOT OF EXCLAMATION POINTS AND
THEN HE GAVE US THE JOE HARRIS
GIFT.
YOU SEE IT RIGHT THERE, JOE
HARRIS, WITH THE SPLASH RIGHT
THERE.
THERE IT IS.
SHOUT-OUT TO, PARLAY PETE.
NOW LET ME HOP IN HERE, CABBIE.
I'M GOING TO KEEP IT REAL
SIMPLE.
I SEE MILWAUKEE WINNING THE TIP.
GIANNIS GETTING THE BALL,
DRIBBLE DRIBBLE, THROW IT LOW.
THROW IT LOW, MY GUY LOPEZ IS
DOWN LOW.
GIVE ME THE BUCKET THERE AND IN
THE OTHER GAME, IN THE OTHER
GAME I HAVE KAWHI AND THEN, THE
CLIPPER GET THE TIP, PASS IT
AROUND A LITTLE BIT.
NICK BATUM FROM THE CORNER.
BATUM FROM THE CORNER WITH THE
THREE SO GIVE ME LOPEZ, BATUM,
PARLAY.
>> HE'LL BE RUNNING IN THE
PAINT.
>> REBOUND.
>> OKAY.
PUTBACK, YOUR ODDS ARE CRAZY.
PLUS 19 -- WOW.
THAT'S ALMOST PLUS 2,000.
20,000.
THAT IS A --
>> YEAH.
WHY NOT -- IF WE'RE THROWING
DARTS, WHY NOT REALLY THROW A
DART HERE IF WE'RE THROWING
DARTS.
>> I MIGHT THROW A DART AT ALL
THREE OF US BECAUSE ERIN IS
LEGIT TOO.
ALMOST 47-1.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TAPPING
INTO THE GROUP CHAT PRESENTED BY
FANDUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
GET ON FANDUEL AND LOCK IN A
FIRST BASKET PARLAY.
SOME GREAT VALUE ON THE LONG
SHOTS TO WIN THE NBA
CHAMPIONSHIP SO YOU HAVE TIME IF
YOU'RE INTO THE FUTURES MARKET
AND COME BACK NEXT WEEK FOR MORE
HOODIES AND JERSEYS AND LOCKS.
WE'RE BACK NEXT TUESDAY.
ALONGSIDE ERIN DOLAN AND CABBIE
RICHARDS, WE ARE LEAVING THE
GROUP PAGE.
PEACE.